[Music]
they're afraid you'll clap cause they're
full of crap yeah the latest list of
woke demands bans the act of clapping
hands
debates at local school board meetings
have grown heated as parents push back
against coven restrictions in the
teaching of crt at the center of this is
douglas county colorado named after
douglas county georgia
that's not true i just threw that in
there because it sounded funny where in
an effort to make things safer they're
trying to ban clapping
audience again i'm sorry mckinley that
five-year-old girl if i could just have
you stop again audience this is the
second time i've had to pause
i've clearly stated the expectations we
cannot comment it makes it an unsafe
environment for someone who has a
different perspective
and i will take a break
if we need to
for you to get yourselves to a place
where we can make sure this is a safe
place for everyone
there it is again the word safe anytime
you want to shut someone down claim it's
about being safe we want you to be safe
so please keep your mask on at all times
even outside to ensure your safety we
removed all gun emojis from your
smartphone
and so we can all be safe we banned greg
gutfeld from the planet fitness sauna
oh clap for that
[Applause]
i didn't know that you have to wear a
towel
so
so now it's clapping right but sorry
back in the day if you wanted to be
somewhere with zero clapping you had to
go see brian kill me do stand up
cause they were too busy laughing
thank you you you sure did clear out
those homeless encampments
but seriously first it was silence's
violence then words equal violence now
clapping is unsafe i haven't seen such
fake outrage since rachel dollas all ran
out of afrosheen
no wonder parents are pissed
seriously banning clapping who is that
protecting imagine where this is headed
[Music]
so britain as you know you were caught
clapping in my classroom do you know how
many clapping-related coveted deaths
there were in 2020
zero
okay well
2021 isn't over yet pal okay and as your
math teacher i have one principle
clapping causes division okay and i
won't let it multiply isn't mr daniels
the principle
principle not pre
okay you know what all right if you're
gonna show approval from now on in my
class you do this
don't let him touch
[Music]
try it
hello fbi my student is a terrorist
[Music]
no
i have to say cat that is some amazing
acting by our producer tom a 40 year old
playing a 20 year old college student
he's seen some you know what's up that's
kind of like welcome back cotter we
realized those guys were shaving in 11th
grade i know i know
uh that was a great show it was it
really was based on a true story he went
back to the sweathogs after getting out
and that was his ticket back i don't
think i asked for a description i'm
sorry
but i understand do you even know what
applause sounds like no idea right
because i don't because i am not so
insecure i have to hire people to clap
no no no no you're all out of here
all right
you know what's worse than clapping okay
so i know cat knows that you must know
this cause you were in college like 20
years ago this this stuff graduates
people
people who do this
did you have that snap yes i hate that
yes and i also hate using words like you
know unsafe when you guess what they
mean is uncomfortable but for me i think
it's the opposite to me nothing is less
comfortable than being in a room full of
people and i have no idea how any of
them feel about anything
yes that's scary and it makes you
apparently like okay can i say this can
i say that what are they how they can
react if i say this can i be myself or
do i need to hide my everything that i
am
and if people are clap it's tough harris
[Laughter]
i'm not i'm not for everyone i'm more of
like you know like a
you know like different a special like
special like cult following maybe but
i'm not like you know i could not
probably host a morning show like you do
but i will know that in certain rooms
and i will tone it down if i don't know
then then that is that's that actually
might be unsafe for me that i could get
fired i never thought about that but i
did a speech at a like uh what do you
call it a chamber of commerce thing in
wisconsin and i did my normal thing and
that was i was up there and i'm going
like holy crap i think this is the wrong
crowd
that gives you an opportunity to be like
all right let me pretend to be somebody
else real quick
boy was i right it was the wrong crowd
they tried to unpay me
well i don't remember the story yes yeah
that's true they tried to unpay me they
had a newsletter and they wrote about it
because i swore
i think i said
whatever
which you can't do on the faulkner focus
no
you can't box the french but we love cat
tim i didn't know you had all that other
stuff going on though oh like what the
paranoia
oh my goodness this is why we do not
know this is why this side wants
decriminalization because we need it
professor when you do when you speak
when you're when you do your classes do
anybody do you do you have the same
anxiety when uh when you're looking out
that people are are they understanding
what i'm talking about of course i i
worry whether they understand or not but
they can clap or not clap most of the
time they don't clap because i'm not
funny
this made me laugh
i guess yeah that was a lot
i would think a couple of things is this
through cat this is the real you though
right well no i the problem is i don't
have a way of really pretending i'm too
impulsive
but you know it's always better to know
where you stand it's scarier to be like
what did they think about what i just
said because you have to think about it
at night when you're trying to fall
asleep yeah that's true i wish i
actually had that going on really
because what i have going on
is expressing every thing that i'm
feeling every moment i'm having it yeah
according to my husband but then you do
would you worry about it later or no no
okay that's the second part i need an
outfit it's unscripted
i wish i did wait
she says everything that she thinks and
then she doesn't think about it isn't
she a sociopath
i mean can you diagnose me right now
no i can't say that no
oh no you just don't want to say it for
free
i've never seen a host try to get the
panel to turn on each other
you want to see a fight
jerry springer used to host his show and
then run behind the audience
i am too lazy to beat jerry springer i
want people to turn on each other while
sitting i know you know you don't want
to be in convenience i know i know all
right do you want me to go where are we
going i don't know yeah she was teasing